avec franck papazian co président du
conseil de coordination des
organisations arméniennes de france
bonsoir prendre ma passion merci d'être
avec nous sur rt france les deux parties
ont convenu d'observer la trêve
humanitaire à partir de minuit est ce
que pour vous ça va enfin tenir tout
dépend de l'azerbaïdjan puisqu'ils ont
déjà rompu le cessez-le-feu qui avait
été signé il ya une semaine il a tenu
cinq minutes et donc je suis un peu
choqué de voir la manière dont
l'information est traitée
parce que pendant ça fait trois semaines
effectivement que les arméniens sont
bombardés dans le haut-karabakh que les
villes et les villages sont bombardés et
pendant toute la peau à partir de la
guerre au fait les arméniens se sont
tenues à faire la guerre contre les
soldats n'ont jamais bombardé les villes
mais quand on a vu effectivement que
l'intermède jean bombardaient
bombardaient bombarder les villes et les
villages les arméniens été obligé de se
défendre de résister et également de
répliquer donc en réalité le président
azerbaïdjanais et le président turc ont
décidé de lancer une offensive de grande
envergure contre des army and teramat
également d'arménie pour mettre la main
sur leur al-ahmar et pour mettre la main
également sur le site de la mine alors
on se défend nous sommes dans une
position de défense d'autodéfense en
réalité de résistance et le président
ilham aliev un menteur c'est un assassin
en fait ça fait depuis 1994 qu'ils
violent entre 6000 et 10 mille fois le
cessez le feu
alors je crois qu'il faut un peu
rétablie à la réalité de l'information
ils ont accusé justement l'arménie
d'avoir bombardé des civils la nuit
dernière à gandja la une des villes de
l'azerbaïdjan vous vous dites que c'est
un mensonge la turquie a parlé de crime
de guerre et vous de votre côté vous
parler de génocide est ce qu'on est dans
la surenchère
non je dis juste en réalité que depuis
1994 la cervelle gens violent entre 6000
et 10 me de poids le cessez le feu jeudi
que depuis trois semaines en fait d'un
servette a entamé une guerre de grande
envergure contre l'azerbaïdjan contre la
le haut-karabakh pardon mais aussi
contre l'arménie au mois de juillet déjà
il y avait eu une incursion militaire
sur le territoire arménien il bombe à
ils pilonnent les arméniens du
haut-karabakh
il ya jack à peu près 50 mille arméniens
qui ont dû fuir justement leur maison
parce qu'aujourd'hui elles sont
totalement bombardé donc ça suffit
je crois qu'à un moment donné il faut
rétablir les choses
les arméniens sont les victimes de la
politique criminelle de la turquie et de
l'azerbaïdjan
il est temps que la communauté
internationale intervienne envoie sur
place des forces de sécurité et forces
d'azerbaïdjan la turquie un vrai cessez
le feu alors juste devant la la la
communauté internationale semble pas
très active en tout cas ne parvient pas
à beaucoup de résultats on le voit la
russie a tenté une médiation pour
obtenir justement cette trêve est ce que
ça peut passer par une médiation
internationale ça doit passer par une
médiation internationale mais la turquie
visiblement non on n'en veut pas la
turquie n'en veut pas l'azerbaïdjan ne
veut pas non plus pour la bonne raison
qu'ils veulent mettre la main sur le
karabakh
ils veulent massacrer tous les arméniens
du karabakh les faire partir et la
turquie veut mettre la main sur le
sionisme dans le sud de l'arménie
évidemment qu'ils ne veulent pas
effectivement d'un cce il y en a un qui
doit être instauré ce soir à minuit on
verra bien s'il tient cette fois ci mais
on a bien compris que la turquie et
l'azerbaïdjan veulent constituer un axe
fort et met moscou deux côtés donc ça
c'est important de le signaler
aujourd'hui l'azerbaïdjan veut
s'émanciper de la tutelle de moscou la
turquie veut occuper cette partie du
monde pour mettre en place son vieux
rêve en turc de la turquie à la mer
caspienne jusqu'aux autres républiques
turcophones
je crois que tu un plan dangereux et il
faut le faire à bordeaux
est ce qu'on peut craindre selon vos une
internationalisation de ce conflit
justement avec ce nouvel acteur la
turquie et la russie qui on le rappelle
à des accords de défense avec l'arménie
vous savez la turquie n'hésite pas à
mettre en place sa politique
expansionniste ans l'a bien vu en série
on le voit bien en libye on le voit bien
en méditerranée orientale
on le voit bien
quant à ses intentions dans le caucase
et au delà même du caucase donc je crois
qu'il faut surtout arrêter la turquie il
faut surtout arrêter ailleurs de cannes
stoppèrent de gan stop aliev imposé sur
place la paix les arméniens veulent
vivre en paix sur leur territoire
historique et celle paul couple est ce
que pour vous la seule issue finalement
ce serait pas une reconnaissance
internationale du haut karabakh qui je
le rappelle depuis 30 ans fait l'objet
d'un processus de minsk mais qui
finalement laisse un peu excusez moi du
terme pourrir la situation
est ce que nous réclamons depuis de
nombreuses années déjà
et là maintenant lorsque l'on voit qu'il
n'ya plus d'issue possible et que la
seule issue pour que les arméniens du
haut-karabakh et en paix
c'est la reconnaissance de la république
du haut karabakh effectivement c'est la
solution qui s'impose aujourd'hui au
monde entier nous attendons
effectivement que cette solution qui
était une solution de protection qu est
une solution de justice et qui est une
solution tout court à la résolution des
problèmes dans cette région du monde
soit appliquée et à accepter
donc ça passerait par par l'onu et par
la reconnaissance également de l'arménie
clé qui ne l'a pas fait j'avais dit moi
si je me trompe mais il a fait appel
mais l'arménie ce soutien le haut
karabakh à 1 min la population du haut
karabakh est un miel donc en réalité il
ya aucune difficulté donc l'arménie
reconnaissent la république du haut
karabakh
il faut juste que ça ce une solution et
pas un problème c'est juste une
formalité pour l'arménie il n'y a pas de
frein pour que l'arménie reconnaissent
cette république donc ce dossier selon
vous doit être portée à l'onu je le suis
doivent être portés d'abord par le
groupe de minsk lui même qui est en
charge depuis 1992 de la réunion de ce
conflit c'est un c'est un format
équilibré avec la russie avec la france
et les etats unis c'est au groupe de
minsk en fait de régler cette question
pourquoi selon vous est le groupe de
minsk n'est jamais parvenu à une
solution acceptable pour les deux
parties
parce que l'un servait de gens ne peut
pas la paix parce que l'intervenant a
décidé effectivement à un moment donné
en ce sens armand et ce sur armand
depuis
vingt ans en fait a décidé de régler
cette question
militairement et non pas par la
négociation à ce que des revêtements
toujours refusé tous les plans de paix
qui ont été proposées depuis des années
avec dans la tête la possibilité de
reprendre de prendre le haut karabagh
lézarde derrière question très
rapidement cela pourrait passer par des
territoires concédé on sait que c'est le
haut-karabakh y est à majorité
arménienne mais il y a aussi eu des
conquêtes un petit peu autour de ce haut
karabagh par l'arménie est ce que ça
pourrait passer par une solution
négociée et là il est le rendu en tout
cas de certains de ses territoires les
bains à moi de m'exprimer sur cette
question là ce sont aux négociateurs se
sont représentant de l'arménie mais
aussi aux représentants du haut karabakh
qui doivent revenir autour de la table
des négociations
ils ont leur mot à dire c'est eux qui
vivent sur place et donc nous
l'encourageons physiquement que pour
dans cette phase terminale lui
importante que les représentants du haut
karabakh soit autour de la table
merci beaucoup en tout cas franck
papazian d'avoir répondu ce soir à nos
questions en direct sur arte france